so we can speak to the government's
culture secretary oliver dowden who
joins us now
and good morning mr dowden does feel
like there are some reasons to be
cheerful tomorrow we're going to see six
people being able to meet outside
in england and also outdoor sport
restarting
what's the first thing you're going to
be doing with your newfound freedoms
well actually with my newfound breeders
first thing i'll be doing is going up to
warrington to see some rugby league some
grassroots sports happening that's
one of the things that we promised we do
we get grassroots sports back up and
running first and we've done that
first after schools and i think tomorrow
is an important day
we're making progress with the rollout
of the vaccine we're making progress
through the roadmap which means that we
can take some important steps tomorrow
first of all allowing grass sports to
resume which is so important for our
nation's physical and mental health but
also
ensuring that people can once again meet
their loved ones
outside of course it's important that we
continue to
abide by the rules but this is an
important step back towards normality
and it's a step that we're able to take
because of course the vaccine rollout
has been
going well so far there has been some
concern about bumpiness
over the next month or so but the mail
on sunday were
reporting today that the modern vaccine
could be rolled out to
under 50s in about three weeks time is
that timetable broadly right when should
we expect to see moderna hitting
the uk at the uk well we're still on
track with our timetable so if you
remember we delivered for the most
vulnerable people by mid-february
we're confident that we'll deliver for
all over 50s by the middle
of april and also to the most
vulnerable remaining most vulnerable and
then by the end of july
we'll have vaccinated first dose but
when do we when should we expect
modernist specifically
well we don't get into the details of
supply chains but the health secretary
has indicated that he would expect later
this month we'd start to see moderna
okay and now the sunday times is also
reporting the uk is planning to offer
3.7 million vaccine doses to ireland
is that true is that true well clearly
our first priority is ensuring that we
deliver vaccines
in the united kingdom we clearly don't
currently have a surplus of vaccines uh
should we get to the point where we have
a surplus of vaccines we make decisions
on the allocation of that surplus
and so sorry and so we've also obviously
seen vaccine roll out issues with the eu
there's been a threat to block
exports of astrazeneca to the uk as well
um
deal is said to be close on that what is
actually happening
well we continue to have uh constructive
discussions with the eu
our position is is very clear that the
eu should not be engaging in
blocking exports and that they should
honour the pledge
that ursula von der line gave to prime
minister boris johnson
a short while ago whereby they agreed
that
any contract should be honoured so that
is to say that
if vaccines have been provided in
honoring of the contract
that that should be honored by the eu
and we expect them to abide by that
okay it does feel a little bit like
we're not getting much clarity this
morning
on the vaccines supply issues on the
vaccine roll out
and not telling us what the latest is on
modena despite the fact that we've been
told that we've got this
new vaccine supply wall going on you're
critical of the
eu of course what is the situation when
are we going to be getting the next
supply of vaccines such as moderna in
the uk people are really worried they
want to know
yes i understand people want to know and
we are very clear to people we will
deliver on the promises
that we made so the promise we made was
that by the middle
of april the middle of this month the
first dose of the vaccine
would be available to all over 50s and
the remaining most vulnerable
and we said that by the end of july all
adults would get access to the first
vaccine alongside that
we'd fill in the second doses within 12
weeks as promised
i can assure anyone watching this
program that we remain on course to do
that
because we're on course to do that that
means we're still on course with the
roadmap
which means that we are taking another
important step from tomorrow
towards back doing the things that we
love and this is the approach the
government's been taking
sticking to the roll out of the vaccine
and sticking to this cautious
but hopefully irreversible road map
that's the importance assurance that
people should take and it's only because
we've managed to stick to that path that
we can take those steps tomorrow
so i just don't understand why you won't
be more open about what's happening we
just expected to take it on trust that
all of these things will happen
on the dates you say why won't you just
tell us when we can expect moderna it's
quite a simple question
well first of all i wouldn't say you
have to take us on trust i would say
take us
on our record we said that the most
vulnerable groups of people would get
their vaccine by the middle of february
they got it by the middle of february
we've said that over 50s
and the most vulnerable will get it by
the middle april we'll deliver on that
we've also always said there'll be ups
and downs in the vaccine we're not going
to give a running commentary on the
supply i have also
indicated as a health sector has said
that we do expect moderna to come later
this month people should take the
reassurance
that we have delivered what we promised
so far and that we will continue to do
so
and as a consequence of that we are able
to take these cautious steps from
tomorrow
in removing some of the the most
restrictions
in relation to covert okay the french
foreign minister said that the uk will
struggle
with supplies for second doses but
brussels won't be blackmailed
in his words into exporting uh doses to
try and solve the problem
can you guarantee that everyone will get
their second dose within that 12-week
period
yes of course we have been planning that
all the way through so it's one of the
most important considerations
as we've rolled out the vaccine not only
do we stick to our
pledges in relation to the first vaccine
we must ensure that people get their
second vaccine so in all of our planning
we have factored in getting that that
second dose of the vaccine and indeed
that is
one of the most important thing for the
most elderly and vulnerable that they
get the added protection from that
second dose
okay now of course given the fact that
different countries are very different
stages of
the vaccine rollout one thing that a lot
of people are worried about
are what's going to be happening with
holidays what's going to happen with
summer holidays
is it true the government's considering
like a traffic like system to deal with
that where for example if an amber
option
would allow you to have a shorter
quarantine period but with increased
testing
well we're exploring all these issues as
part of
the international travel task force that
will be
reporting at the beginning of next month
grant chapter transport secretary is
leading on that
so that we will set out to the next
steps as as part of that process
so you are considering it then
we we consider all options as as part of
the
uh the the the travel task force i think
you'd expect that
when government formulates policy the
way we do this is we look at all the
different options
we weigh them up we come to a position
and then when we've come to that
position
we publish that position and that's the
the position that we'll be setting out
at the beginning of of next month
clearly there are challenges around
international travel you only have to
look across the continent
and see the the rising case rates in
many of our nearest
neighbors it has been in the past the
case that those rising infection rates
have seen their way through to the
the uk we're hopeful that that won't
happen
this time around because of our progress
with the vaccine and and so on but we do
need to be cautious about that that is
that is why we are just
we've we've got this review we're
looking at it carefully and you'll get
the results of that at the beginning of
next month
okay uh considering all options we look
forward to a bit more detail
on that let's see if i can get a bit
more detail on something else and you've
said you've been looking at vaccine
passports as a way of
allowing people to go back to for
example live sporting events and is that
likely to happen
and how is it going to work
well this is an important uh
consideration one of a range of
different mitigations that we are
using to probe to look at looking at as
we progress
through the the roadmap so if you
remember sophie uh we've made the
commitment that all being well
stage three by the 15th of may we'll get
back to essentially the position we were
last summer so for example you'll be
able to have social distancing
indoors and outdoors but that means that
many areas of our national life for
example
theatres or large sporting events still
don't remain viable
and it's really essential that we get to
the point where by those things can
operate
viably commercially and that means some
further easing of restrictions that's
why we said by stage four we'll look to
remove
as many of those restrictions as we
possibly can now we're conducting a
range of pilots
as to how we can achieve that and we're
looking at all sorts of factors
so for example ventilation we're looking
at behavior
we're looking at the spread risk so
we're testing before and
after but it's also important that as
part of that we consider the role that
covert certification
might play now that work is being led by
my colleague the chancellor of the duchy
of lancaster
and it's an important factor that we
need to consider as part of this
okay um as you said it's been an
incredibly
difficult time for a lot of the
industries that your brief touches on
whether it's sport whether it's
culture whether it's hospitality of
course very linked
to some of those big venues as well
now your department's been given almost
2 billion pounds to support the culture
sector
has all that money being given out now
well remember the the first allocation
was one and a half billion pounds so
that's for this financial year
we've already announced a billion pounds
worth of that helping over 4 000
organizations
up and down the country so for example
i'll be going up to
wolverhampton tomorrow to see the the
theater there another beneficiary of
that
and at the end of this week we'll
announce the remaining allocations to
take us up to the one and a half
billion pounds that will see those
organizations through to the end of
june then the chancellor announced that
the budget a further allocation of 300
million pounds
the focus of that really is about
helping those organizations
reopen and restart as we progress along
the roadmap and we'll be opening
applications for that
final phase very shortly i'm struggling
to see why
it's taken so long to get the money to
where it's really needed because the
1.57 million was announced
last 1.57 billion sorry lance announced
last july
you say a billion of that has been given
out national order office found only 495
million paid out by
february of this year when
you know we've seen reports of theaters
closing of you know
football clubs on their knees of live
music venues shutting down forever why
is it taking so long to actually get
some of this money out
well so there's there's a range of
different points you you raise there
first of all
uh clearly things have moved on since
the national audit office report in
february
we did make a conscious choice though
it's just to come in
like just to come in there because i i
accept your point that things have moved
on since february but this money was
was announced in july so it's been
pretty slow
sorry i was trying to i was trying to
answer the the second point which is
that we did make a conscious choice in
relation to the remaining 400 million we
held that back
because we wanted to see how we
progressed through this year and from
the conversations we had with theaters
and other organizations
they wanted us to have that flexibility
we'll be announcing the allocation of
that that further amount of money we've
rolled forward
the time they can use that until the end
of june and then clearly we haven't been
able to allocate the
the the extra 300 million the chance to
just announce that in the budget and
that was always intended for the
the next financial year and to help that
recovery process you also mentioned
sport
just today we've announced uh most of
the remainder of the sports winter
survival package
and again we'll be moving on to the
summer survival package
that will apply from the beginning of
the new financial year and in relation
to all of those in relation to theaters
our sporting institutions up and down
the country
i remember when this crisis first hit i
was being warned
that we could lose vast swathes of our
culture and sporting life
it is only thanks to those interventions
that we have made that we've been able
to protect them and the
vast majority of our theaters the vast
majority of our sports clubs
have been protected thanks to that in
those interventions that sit alongside
things like the furlough scheme and
others that have helped our national
life
survive the terrible impacts of the
covert restrictions
while we're on sports and culture what's
the latest on whether the euros could be
held in england
well we are committed to holding the
euros and uh we fully expect that
the euros will happen so yes they are
they are going ahead
uh as planned the the big moments of the
euros are going to happen in the uk so
that's to say
the semi-finals and the finals with some
group matches as well it's always been
the case that other matches will take
place
across europe and we expect that to
remain the case okay that makes sense
and
sticking on football and the england
captain harry kane
has said that the squad needs to have a
real think about whether or not to join
other national teams who are protesting
about human rights abuses in qatar who
of course are going to be at the venue
for
the world cup in 2022. do you think the
uk and the england football team need to
be a bit stronger in calling out qatar's
record on human rights
well we as a government never hesitate
in calling out human rights
abuses where wherever they happen in
terms of the actions that england
football players take i've always said
it's
it's up to them it's not for me as
culture secretary to be prescribing what
they they should and shouldn't do they
they'll they'll act appropriately and
they'll make decisions between
themselves
so it's up to football it's not
government ministers then
so so for government ministers we have
been absolutely clear in terms of
calling out human rights abuses in terms
of
actions that footballers themselves take
that's clearly up to them
um david cameron is being investigated
by a lobbying watchdog the one he set up
actually over his work for
greenville finance group since leaving
number 10.
now this was originally reported by the
financial times him contacting rishi
soon next private phone to try and get
access
uh for that company to a loan scheme
set up by the government now the sunday
times details this morning how lex
greensell who set up this company
was given some pretty extraordinary
access to government when david cameron
was prime minister at the time you were
david cameron's
deputy chief of staff did you ever met
meet lex greensell did you raise any
concerns about the access that he was
given
well i've been racking my brains i took
to the very best of my recollection
i never met with them but i can't say
for for sure i'd have to
to check over the the records but i have
zero recollection i'm pretty sure that i
i didn't meet with them but i think you
you raised investigation i believe that
david cameron has been uh cleared uh as
as a result of that
and uh any appropriate meetings will of
course be properly
declared and i don't there was any
change in in government policy and
certainly from working with david
cameron
over a number of years i always found
him a man of the utmost integrity and
i've no doubt that would pertain in this
situation as well
quite a lot of the allegations in the
sunday times this morning
are talking about how lex grinza was
given access through
jeremy hayward of course head of the
civil service at that point is that
something that
should raise any concerns or do you
think it merits further investigation
no i think all of these things will have
been properly declared i remember when i
worked in downing street we had very
tight restrictions about the
declarations of
meetings those would be fully in the the
public domain
uh clearly and sadly jeremy hayward is
no longer
with us but again he was somebody that
always uh abided punctiliously with the
the rules uh in relation to engaging
with with third parties
okay and just finally there's been an
outpouring of allegations about
harassment
assault abuse against uh some of
britain's leading private schools um
what's happening is there an
investigation that's taking place and
how important
is it that the government prioritizes
this
these are very serious allegations and
clearly
any child at school or indeed anyone
needs to
feel safe and if there are concerns that
people have they must raise them with
responsible adults or with the police
uh in terms of the the actual steps
being taken uh the
is the independent schools uh
investigation
uh an inspection regime and the the dfe
can call
them in and we'll we'll deal with that
as appropriate so either take measures
uh to deal with those safeguarding
issues or ultimately to to close the
school so we have those in uh
independent
inspection regimes and it's important
those uh are undertaken as appropriate
okay oliver doubt and thank you very
much for being on the show this morning
oliver dowden